did the human brain evolve
to think that's essentially
the question that you address in the
essay can you speak to it
sure you know the the big caveat here is
that
we don't really know why brains evolved
the big
why questions are called teleological
questions
and um in general scientists
should avoid those questions because we
don't know really what we don't know the
why
however for for
a very long time the assumption was that
evolution worked in a progressive upward
scale
that you start off with simple organisms
and those organisms get more complex and
more complex and more complex
now obviously that's true in some like
really general way right
that that um life started off as single
cell organisms and
you know things got more complex but the
idea that
um that brains evolved in some upward
trajectory from simple brains in simple
animals to complex brains in complex
animals
is called a phylogenetic scale
and that phylogenetic scale
is embedded in a lot of evolutionary
thinking including darwin's
actually and it's
been seriously challenged i would say by
modern
evolutionary biology and so
you know thinking is something that
rationality is something that humans at
least in the west
really prize as a great
human achievement and so the idea that
the most common evolutionary story is
that you know
brains evolved in like sedimentary rock
with you know a layer for instincts
that's your lizard brain
and a layer on top of that
for emotions that's your limbic system
limbic meaning border
so it borders the parts that are for
instincts oh interesting
and um and then um the uh
neocortex or new cortex where um
rationality is supposed to live that's
the sort of traditional story
it just keeps getting layered on top
right by evolution right
and so you can think about you know
i mean sedimentary rock is the way
typically people describe it the way
i sometimes like to think about it is um
you know thinking about the cerebral
cortex like uh
icing on an already baked cake you know
um where you know the cake is your inner
beast
these like boiling you know roiling
instincts and emotions that have to be
contained
and the the by the cortex
and the the it's just um it's a fiction
it's a myth
it's a myth that you can trace all the
way back to
stories about morality um in ancient
greece
what you can do is look at the
scientific record and say well there
there's others there are other stories
that you could tell about brain
evolution and
and the the context in which brains
evolved
so when you look at creatures who don't
have brains
and you look at creatures who do
what's the difference and
you can look at you know some animals
um so we call scientists call an
environment that an animal lives in
a niche their environmental niche what
are the things
what are the parts of the environment
that matter to that animal and
so there are some animals whose niche
hasn't changed in 400 million years
so they're they're not these creatures
are modern creatures but they're
living in a niche that hasn't changed
much and so their biology hasn't changed
much and you can
kind of verify that by looking at the
genes that lurk
deep you know in the molecular structure
of cells
and so you can by looking at various
animals in their developmental state
meaning not you don't look at adult
animals you look at embryos of animals
and
developing animals you can see you can
piece together a different story and
that story
is that brains evolved under
the selection pressure of hunting that
in the cambrian period hunting emerged
on the scene where animals
deliberately ate one another um
and what so you know before
the cambrian period the animals didn't
really have well they didn't have brains
but they also didn't have
senses really the very very rudimentary
senses so
the animal that i wrote about in um
seven and a half lessons is called an
amphioxus or a lancelet
and um little amphioxus
has no eyes it has no ears it has no
nose it it it has no eyes it has a
couple of
cells for um uh detecting light and dark
for circadian rhythm
purposes so and it it it
can't hear it has a vestibular cell to
keep its body
upright it has a very rudimentary sense
of touch
and it doesn't really have any internal
organs other than this like
basically stomach it's like a just like
a
it doesn't it doesn't have an enteric
nervous system it doesn't have like
a gut that you know moves like we do it
just has
basically a tube yeah um so it's like a
container
like a little container yeah and so and
really it doesn't
it doesn't move very much it can move it
just sort of wriggles
it doesn't have very sophisticated
movement and it's this really sweet
little
animal it sort of wriggles its way to a
spot and then plants itself
in the sand and just filters food as the
food goes by
um and then when the food concentration
decreases
it it just it it just um ejects itself
wriggles to the net some spot randomly
where probabilistically there will be
more food
and plants itself again so it's it's not
it's not really aware very aware that it
has an
environment it has a niche but that
niche is very small and
it's not really experiencing that niche
very much
um so it's it's basically like a little
stomach on a stick
that's that's really what it is and
um but but when animals
start to literally hunt each other
all of a sudden it becomes important to
have
to be able to sense your environment
because you need to know
is that blob up ahead going to eat me
or should i eat it and so all of a
sudden you want
distant senses are very useful and so in
the water
distant senses are vision
and a little bit hearing
um olfaction smelling
and touch because in the water touch is
a distant sense because
you can feel the vibration so it's right
so
in um on air on land you know vision is
a distant sense touch not so much
but for elephants maybe right um the
vibrations
vibrations um well faction definitely
because of the concentration of you know
look more concentrated something is the
more likely it is to be close to you
you